le calme est finalement revenu
aujourd'hui à château renault a prévu
après une impression après un
impressionnant dispositif de sécurité
déployé hier après midi et jusqu'à tard
dans la soirée
plus d'une soixantaine de gendarmes sont
intervenus dans cette commune du nord
touraine
suite à un tir de plomb sur une mineure
deux hommes se sont finalement rendus ce
matin alors beaucoup de bruit pour rien
la réponse avec paul boyer et samuel
cola ils se sont finalement rendus ce
matin deux jeunes hommes identifiés dès
hier soir par les enquêteurs
à 21h30 le gign annonce la fin de son
intervention la population n'est pas
considérés en danger aux abords de la
rue de la république ce matin et dans la
ville une drôle de journée se termine
ça c'est chez moi je t'aime beaucoup ont
d'ailleurs jugé salle afin d'assurer
n'ont eu d'autres histoires pas de cette
ampleur avec le gg nutr où j'habite
s'est donné en face de l'habitation où
la personne était retranché du coup bas
au début on savait pas mais une fois
qu'on a su bas et c'est sûr ça fait un
peu peur l'armé utilisée serait une
carabine à plombs la jeune fille blessée
à la jambe est emmené à l'hôpital
d'amboise et en sort quelques heures
après mais le dispositif en cas de tir
avec armes à feu est déployé sur place
45 gendarmes
seize militaires du gign trois
négociateurs et une équipe cynophile
priorité assurer la sécurité des
habitants et notamment la sortie des
écoles
eh bien on a fait attention aux enfants
justement parce que c'était la sortie
scolaire et on les a gardé un petit peu
en confinement le temps que l'on sache
un petit peu comment elle est sécurisée
pour sortir une enquête est ouverte pour
violences avec arme
elle a été confiée à la brigade
d'amboise les deux jeunes hommes ont été
placés en garde à vue